but joining me now is a governor who
refused to give into the left's demands
and lockdown requests
governor christie gnome of south dakota
governor it's great to have you on
tonight you have been
lambasted in the press for not stripping
your residents
of their basic freedoms and their right
to work and go to school
but here uh we are about now six months
into this pandemic and south dakota
still has a death rate
11 times lower than new york's
per 100 000 people amazing
yeah we're doing very well laura and
that's really the story that needs to be
told
is that i trusted my people they trusted
me
they took personal responsibility for
dealing with this virus
and we're doing very well not only do we
have one of the lowest death rates we've
had got
about 40 people that are in the hospital
today statewide
our infection rates are low our job
losses are low our economy is doing
better than virtually any other state
and i think it's a real testimony to
what could have been possible in many of
these other states that the governors
just made the wrong decisions
well despite this overwhelming evidence
governor noam including as you just said
from your state
the left is still urging
national lock downs watch
lock downs work quarantine works
isolation works wearing masks work
contact tracing works these things work
and we're not doing them if we were to
lock down hard for a month or six weeks
we could get the case count down so that
our testing and our contact tracing was
actually enough
to control it governor your state proves
this is just not the case
and we don't need to strip the people of
their freedom to fight the virus
you know what works is washing your
hands making good decisions
i think what we're seeing there is
encouraging leaders
to make decisions that where they will
overstep their authorities in a time of
crisis
and that's how we lose this country
laura that is exactly what's happening
is that we are allowing them to take
control
of our country in a way that we haven't
seen before so we need a few people to
stand up read our history
talk about the importance of our
constitution and the fact that these
governors need to recognize that they
need to uphold those freedoms that we
hold so dear and allow these people to
take care of their families and make the
right decisions
and deal with this virus much like we do
every other challenge that comes our way
and americans tackle it together what
i'm frustrated by
what is just the night go go ahead sorry
what
what would have happened to your state's
economy
had we listened to this dr hazeltine or
any of these other
officials neil kashgari at the fed i
don't know why he's
supposedly an expert at this but what
would have happened to your economy and
your people
well they would have been devastated we
would have lost businesses families that
would have lost their homes
we would have seen so many more people
still continue to get sick
still be hospitalized but they'd be
doing it with less resources to take
care of each other
and less of an ability to really go
forward and provide for their families
so that's the challenge here is that
our state is so diverse we have very
urban areas but we also have very rural
areas
and a blanket approach doesn't make
sense for the entire state of south
dakota it doesn't make sense
for this entire country and that's why
we need local leaders
to trust people in their communities to
make the decisions that work
best for them and we also need them to
be optimistic laura
i mean this this negativity that we hear
from leaders and doctors about
how terrible the situation is in our
country we're in a good spot
we are driving down our death rates the
virus is moving across the country but
we're taking
care of people they're getting the
resources the administration has helped
governors respond to their people
i worry about these kids that turn on
the news and hear their parents talking
about being
scared and hear news anchors talking
about being worried and doctors
we wonder why our kids are struggling
with anxiety let's be optimistic
there's concern about this uh
big motorcycle rally that's happening
this weekend
in south dakota and we don't have to
play the sound bite though oh my god on
television all the cable news
how dare you it's going to become a
super spreader event governor a big
super spreader event look at all those
people look at how they gather
well we've had several big events in
south dakota already we had the first
spectator attended a professional sport
the professional bull riding was held in
south dakota
we had the july 3 event and saw no
increase in cases because of that crowd
that gathered to celebrate
our country's freedom and independence
people have been gathering we've been
back to normal for over three months
here in south dakota
so we know we can have these events give
people information
let them protect their health but still
enjoy their way of life
and enjoy events like the sturgis
motorcycle rally we hope people come
our economy benefits when people come
and visit us well lucky
lucky residents and citizens of the
great state of south dakota because
we're stuck in the
d.c metropolitan area with horrible
leadership
and governor we just wish you the best
of luck this weekend and going forward
and check back with us soon
well thank you laura appreciate it